tonight was the final presidential
debate thank Christ
where the mannequins from Ann Taylor and
Spencer Gifts they duped it out to win
undecided voters but we're just not
ready to say goodbye to debate so
comedians to keep the conflict alive a
little bit longer I'm gonna give you a
famous issue and whoever buzzes in first
should weigh in to settle it once and
for all
first up cats versus dogs Andrew dogs
because I'm lonely but I'm not that
lonely all right yep cats because that
office chair isn't gonna fun itself yeah
that'll rebuttal dogs cats tastes
disgusting
all right boys next up I know this is a
very important issue and everyone hand
jobs versus dry humping that looks like
kind of wet humping on the beach though
I don't know if then either I'll take
whatever I can get it yeah points
can judge because we need more jobs in
this
six-one black versus white black versus
white let's be very careful with this
one let's be very careful with this one
sir
he's having one of the three black dudes
in the audience ago yeah we got this all
right we got this Adam it's black
because the darkness comes for us all
yeah we can pretend it's not wasting our
time with little interactive Twitter
games but eventually the black consumes
us all all right